- This here is a picture
of the ground finch
of the Galapagos Islands.
And one of its primary sources of food
is seeds that it finds on the ground.
And if we go back to 1976,
we can look at the
distribution of beak depths.
And these beak depths,
I would assume these are
given in millimeters.
Finches are quite small birds.
And you can see in 1976,
you have a large number of finches
that had a beak depth of 8.8 millimeters,
but it was a distribution around that.
Now, after this data was collected,
it turns out there was a drought
and there were fewer seeds.
So the smaller seeds,
which were easy to eat
for all of these finches,
would have been consumed quickly.
And all that would have been
left were the larger seeds,
the ones that you need a larger beak
in order to crack and
get at the good stuff.
So what do you think would have happened
to the distribution of beak depths
over the course of the next two years?
Well, you might guess that the birds,
the finches that have larger beak depths,
are more likely to survive
because they're more likely
to be able to crack the larger seeds.
And the finches that are
more likely to survive
are also more likely to reproduce,
and pass their large beak
trait to their offspring.
And that is indeed what
scientists observed.
As we go from 1976 to 1978,
the distribution has shifted a
pretty good bit to the right.
Now the most common beak depth is 9.8.
So this is an example of an
environmental change, a drought,
changing the food supply,
because now there's fewer
small seeds available,
that changed a distribution in beak depths
over just two years.
Now, environmental changes
don't always cause adaptation.
If it's too severe,
if the drought was so strong
that there were no seeds,
you could have extinction.
So the species disappears altogether.
But here we have an example
that in just two years,
a species was actually able
to adapt a pretty good bit.
Now, no individual member of the species
knew to somehow grew their beak.
But as we saw, you always have
a variation of beak depths.
And year after year,
the birds with the bigger beak depth,
were more likely to survive and reproduce.
So the species as a whole
adapted to the new
environmental conditions.